>>Janice Lombardi: Right in here.
This is wonderful.
>>Counselor: So I'm going to be
talking with you today about ways
that students can prepare for college.
The application process, filling
out financial aid paperwork,
and scholarships.
>>Counselor: [Speaking Spanish].
>>Janice Lombardi: Over 80 percent
of our students are first-time
college goers.
And Early College gives them a lift up.
And not only does it change their lives,
but it changes their families' lives.
>>Janice Lombardi: An Early
College, by definition,
serves underserved students,
first-time college goers.
As a consequence, they
don't have experience
in the study skills,
the academic background.
>>Kenya: When you come from a family
that doesn't have school experience,
like, for example, my dad, he
dropped out of fourth grade,
my mom just got her GED, coming to
this school kind of helped me find
that motivation to succeed.
>>Travis Smith: The ideal situation
is that a student will graduate
with their diploma as well
as their Associates degree.
>>Georgette: With this school, you
have two years of college experience
on a full tuition, so you
don't have to pay the classes.
As an incoming freshman, I
was not confident at all.
Teachers always supported me, and
they said that I was very bright,
and that I was going to blossom.
>>Janice Lombardi: We take
each student and grow them
into phenomenal college ready students.
And we do that through
a variety of strategies.
We start with college classes
that are not intensely academic.
>>Kenya: They give us,
basically, the easier classes.
And then as we start going up, sophomore
year starts getting a little bit harder.
>>Janice Lombardi: And
in the tenth grade year,
they can take college
trig, college algebra.
>>Kenya: So as you start going up,
the classes start getting harder,
the work starts getting heavier.
And it gets pretty tough at times.
>>Sam Rodgers: So of course,
that means the radius is 7P.
>>It's beneficial that they
can get high school credit
and college credit as well.
They get the same course,
and everything is expected
of all students that are enrolled.
>>Felonie: Taking the dual credit
classes, you have to be responsible
and decide, "I'm going
to take this lesson home.
I'm going to get in a study group."
If you don't, well then
you fail, and it's on you.
>>Janice Lombardi: The supports that
we offer to our students are varied.
We do offer counseling support.
One of the things that we see with
this scaffolded instruction is
that students become anxious.
And so we have counselors
who can identify their
strengths, what they want to do.
>>Miss Crawford: All right, so
go ahead, look at the choices
that you have for next year.
>>Juan: Miss Crawford is great.
She always tries to make sure I
get the best schedule I can have.
I'm trying to balance out my classes enough, so I can get to my goal,
which is Associates degree,
or at least close to it.
>>Miss Crawford: Put your
dual credit check there.
You also have to take the
Economics and Government.
Those two are needed to graduate.
And then, of course, we'll
give you a Ace Period,
which is time for you to study.
>>Janice Lombardi: We have
dedicated Study Halls for students,
because we know, given
their home circumstances,
they may not have a place
to study, or a computer.
>>Sigifredo: It's very useful to me,
'cause it helps me catch up on my work.
>>Xitlally: College classes
are sometimes hard,
because they give us a lot of tests.
So we have to study, study, study.
>>Eduardo: We strongly believe
that it has helped our daughter
amazingly getting her experience
in college.
>>Janice Lombardi: Parents
are an essential ingredient
in this whole Early College movement.
We do treat them as equal partners here.
>>How are you doing today?
>>Good, how about you?
>>Good, good.
>>Parent: The high school
that has assisted us
with applications for universities.
>>Counselor: Colleges will be looking
at the student's high school transcript.
>>Counselor: [Speaking Spanish].
>>Janice Lombardi: Our culture of high
expectations really means you can do it.
>>Good to see you.
>>"If you will join us, we'll
go down this pathway together.
You will be successful."
>>Kenya: It's helped me
mature throughout these years.
I currently have 21 credits, and I'm
taking four college classes right now.
So I should have my Associate's
degree in 2016.
>>Georgette: Having four younger
brothers that are aspiring
to pursue higher education, I want
them to see that dreams do come true
if you pursue it with your
heart and with passion.
After graduation, I plan to
attend Baylor University,
and then go on to UT
Southwestern Medical School.